y empecemos por lo más básico
explíquenos que es la viruela del mono
cómo se propaga y especialmente cómo
evitarla
bueno es una enfermedad viral que se
está viendo como zoonótica eso quiere
decir que puede pasar de los animales al
hombre y esa es la preocupación y la
alerta es una enfermedad que produce una
ninguna una sintomatología con unas
pústulas en pie y la razón por la cual
todo el mundo está tan preocupado es
porque la viruela solita era una
infección que causaba que causó la
muerte de mucha gente en el siglo 18 el
siglo 18 siglo 19 y gracias a ella se
lograron en la cruz bruce las primeras
vacunas las primeras vacunas que se
hicieron en la historia en la ciencia se
hicieron contra el virus de la viruela
porque era muy mortal y muy preocupante
en humanos ahora hay viruela de moore no
hay viruela de vaca hay viruela en ese
cerdo hay vive la de muchos animales y
la preocupación es que el hombre también
tuvo viruela pero gracias a la vacuna se
radicó ahora puede pasar del hombre del
animal al hombre y produciendo unas
lesiones
y el
postular es pústulas y costras y eso es
lo que está preocupando critica al mundo
que como fue una infección tan grave en
un momento y generó tantos problemas de
salud la preocupación es que pueda
llegar a convertirse esta viruela que
estaba crítica no nos en en un problema
en humanos y precisamente usted nos
habla de la conexión entre viruela y la
viruela del mono a propósito este tema
la v s advirtió que desde que la viruela
se erradicó en el mundo en 1980 la
viruela del mono se convirtió en el
poxvirus más importante de la salud
pública porque el aumento y cuál es su
relación con la viruela
pues es que los virus de ese mismo virus
los pocos virus como usted lo está
diciendo son un grupo de vídeos de ácido
nucleico dna eso quiere decir que es
distinto al que teníamos hace un rato el
del gol que estamos todavía esperando
que se termine de ir que era un virus rn
a este es un virus de enea y tiene una
capacidad de producir en el humano un
problema muy serio de una alta
mortalidad entonces esa es la
preocupación ahora en los animales tiene
diferentes grados de mortalidad de
letalidad dependiendo de la situación y
dependiendo del animal pero tenemos
animales pues que en este momento como
el mono están manifestando la infección
y eventualmente la pueden pasar al
humano cuando se la pasan al humano la
infección no es tan agresiva no es
mortal en el mar o la posibilidad mortal
y acá es muy bajita entonces pues en
principio es la preocupación y la bs
también dijo que la viruela del mono se
da principalmente en las selvas
tropicales de áfrica central y
occidental cuéntenos en qué condiciones
se propaga este virus y qué tan
vulnerable es américa latina por sus
condiciones ambientales
en áfrica en general es un sitio donde
fácilmente aparecen virus nuevos por
ejemplo el virus del ébola el
chikungunya el cica todos estos virus
han salido del áfrica y no
necesariamente tienen éxito cuando salen
y hemos visto en ejemplo pues
efectivamente cuando arrancó el 5 ya
teníamos unas expectativas de que iba
podría ser una pandemia y realmente no
logró tener éxito por fuera de áfrica
por mucho tiempo en cicaa aunque tuvo es
más hacia atado más
a otros países diferentes pues no fue
tan agresivo como podría haber sido y
obviamente la preocupación es que uno
que otro virus que salga de áfrica pueda
contagiar y pueda contagiar a los
humanos y producir lesión como se
transmite pues se transmite por contacto
con el virus hay que tocar el virus hay
que tener alguna vía de contacto con el
virus para transmisión si no entonces
pues de vía respiratoria no poco pero
sobre todo contacto con el virus
físicamente